la casa blanca señaló que la expulsión
de una docena de diplomáticos rusos de
la onu se ha estado preparando durante
meses mientras se tomaba el tiempo para
verificar sospechas a eeuu informó a las
naciones unidas y a la misión rusa ante
naciones unidas que se inició con el
proceso de expulsión de 12 agentes de
inteligencia de la misión rusa quienes
abusaron de sus privilegios de
residencia en estados unidos
participando en actividades de espionaje
las autoridades estadounidenses han
emprendido otra acción hostil contra la
misión rusa ante las naciones unidas
violando flagrantemente sus compromisos
sobre el acuerdo con el país anfitrión
cantrill y grimón las expulsiones se
produjeron durante una sesión especial
de emergencia en la que los 193 miembros
de la asamblea general de la onu fueron
convocados para debatir sobre una
resolución que exige a rusia la retirada
inmediata de sus fuerzas de ucrania
votación que tendrá lugar el miércoles
[Música]
rusia enfrentándose a un aislamiento
global cada vez mayor buscó justificar
el asalto como una medida defensiva pero
el embajador ucraniano expresó que las
palabras y las acciones no coinciden
louis no escucha las mentiras rusas
louis
escuchen los gritos de ucranianos por
otra parte el ministro de asuntos de
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov canceló
su visita prevista al consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu en ginebra
este martes esto coincide con las
sanciones financieras impuestas por
suecia contra el presidente ruso y su
primer ministro mientras tanto los
negociadores regresaron a moscú y kiev
tras cinco horas de conversaciones de la
frontera ucraniana con el arroz durante
la reunión se acordó mantener los
diálogos ya que en los próximos días se
celebrarán nuevas negociaciones de la
frontera entre polonia y belarús